I don't know a lot of lotion people but
I know that they do this Bath and Body
Works is a store that I never want to go
in at the mall but I always get dragged
to it by my girlfriend early
two-thousands Oh like my girlfriends
we're like 12 but we're like let's go I
think they have a lot of soap and I
think that they have a lot of baskets
that have soap in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this feels like something that like a
twelve-year-old girl would wear like I'm
walking through the woods and like
medieval England and I'm picking a
cherry and I smell it I would call this
watermelon body butter dainty moon berry
sunrise okay that was a bad idea this we
called holy crap don't spray this and
who work near children because they will
light on fire
laundry's done that's what this should
be called cuz it does smell very fresh
I'd wear it oh this smells like hair
spray can cause Aqua Net old lady's
house by Bed Bath & Beyond plume
Meredith that's awful oh happy birthday
honey
I got you plumeria what you got me a
disease no it's this awesome fragrance
from Bath and Body Works looks like I'm
about to put some mayo on my skin this
is like I'm in Paris France like hanging
out with Kanye West it's just got to be
lemon hand lotion this is why I don't
use lotion cuz my hands feel creepy
right now oh I hate to be talking about
poop right now it's not my spell but
that's how bad this smells oh I would
buy this for my girlfriend for sure
I like this one but this again just a
little too very juvenile No
at Bed Bath and Beyond they just do
whatever the hell they want they like
makeup smells they makeup or what did I
say
hello friend I would recognize her
anywhere man I want to eat this one this
one smells like candy I feel like this
one would be like the Britney Spears of
like the lotion I can't stop smelling my
hands
they just smell great Bath & Body Works
you know thank you for everything you've
done the past 20 years you've helped a
lot of stinky teens make it through in
the 90s I was a little kid I was
smelling play-doh and 64 cartridges Jack
bath and body has some good stuff there
probably still won't go but I appreciate
them for what they are I didn't tell my
girlfriend that I was gonna be in this
I'm I'm wondering what she's gonna think
when I get home like come home with
smelling like a 90s girl